[موسيقى]
اسمي مصطفى نادر عمري 20 سنه مصور ورسام
ومشروع كاتب
صغير كنت مؤمن انه ماكو فواصل بحياه
الانسان اكتوبر
2014 اجريت تحليلات بسيطه الكتور كان قاعد
على المز قال عندك بس
سرطان كانت صدمه خلتني اضحك هوايه وابتسم
هوايه وافرط بهذا
الابتسامه ما اعرف الابتسامه كان شنو
نوعها عن الم لو عن تعب لو عن خوف ما كان
احد يدري بالموضوع اختلافي كنت عن بقيه
مرض
السرطان شنت لوحدي رحت للدكتور لوحدي طول
هها الفتره لوحدي استمريت شهر كامل
تقريبا يلا
رحت وقلت لاهلي وقلت لاصدقائي وشاركت
الموضوع عبر الفيسبوك كنت طول هاي الفتره
ابحث عن جود اكزامبل يعني مثال حي للحاله
مثل مريض سرطان انتصر على المرض
ونج وصار زين بس المشكله ما لقيت وياه
يقوله انا عندي سرطان يجاوبني ب الطريقه
يعني يقوللي عمي كان ب نفس المرض
ومات يعني هوايه هوايه ناس هقولي جدي كان
بنفس مرض مات كانت الناس احسها تنتظرني
اموت يعني الله يساعدك خطيه الشفقه
يعني المشكله الامل ما شفته من احد اكثر
كلمه كان يقوللي اياها الله يشافيك احس
نفسي مخبط من يقولها
شوي المشكله احنا انا انا بديت نوعا ما
احبط شويه يقل تفائلي واملي بس للحظه فكرت
انه اكون اني المثال والجود اكزامبل
والشخص اللي يلهم مرضى
السرطان كان
حلم اهت كل احلامي يعني لم تعد هناك اهميه
لكل مهم بحياتي ما كانت اكو احلام بعد
انتهت الرسم
والتصوير كل شي انتهى كنت افكر بس شلون
انجو من
المرض فتره العلاج الكيمياوي ما اعرف هو
اسم علاجي يعني فعلا سمي يدخل الجسد وقع
شعري وذت نفسيتي زايد بس
بوقتها كنت اريد اثبت للدكتور مالتي اللي
قال لي بعد لك 100 يوم تموت والناس اللي
قطعت املي بالحياه انه اناي اقدر اعيش
وتحياتي للدكتور وليد اللي هو موجود اليوم
ويانا اللي هو من الناس اللي ساعدوني
بشفائي تسويق حار
[تصفيق]
له الجديد اللي اني سويته بهذا الحدث
مالتي انه اني حولت مفهوم المرض الى حرب
وبدل ما اقول انا مريض سرطان اقول انا
محارب لمرض السرطان وكنت البس وياي طول
هالفتره هاي البيريه اخفي بها القرعه
مالتي يعني بس انا من صرت اقرع وقع شعري
استعديت لستايل جديد يعني قلت اوكي انا ما
واقع شعري بحياتي اغلب صوري كبشات بس كنت
دائما انزل صوري بالفيسبوك وعبر كل مكان
انه ان م خايف ومبتسم حولت السرطان الى
مرض بسيط اشبه بالفلون صار مرض تافه كلش
بس رغم الماسات والاشياء اللي اصابتني انا
بقيت مصطفى نادر بقيت اكتب وارسم واصور
واشار كل اشيائي على الفيسبوك واستمر ويا
الناس اليوم انا اريد ابشر مرض السرطان
انه السرطان مرض مو مستعصي السرطان مرض
نفسي يصيب الانسان ويقدر اي شخص يتشاف من
عنده اليوم انا احكي اكثر من 250 مريض
سرطان واحاول اكون لهم الجود اكزامبل
والحياه موجوده قدامنا احنا ما نموت وما
تموت ابتسامتنا ان شاء الله المرض يصيب
جسد الانسان بس ما يصيب روحه احنا موجودين
واح راح نبقى اللي يريد يعرف اكثر تفاصيل
وال يريد يشوف مصطفى نادر اكثر يعني موجود
بال خارج بعد الاستراحه راح تشوفوني ي
البورد مالتي باسمي تحياتي الكم واتمنى
لكم جميعا شكرا
جزي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جزي
ا
[تصفيق]
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
انا اسمي سامر اياد انا طالب في كليه طب
الاسنان اناي من البصره اصلا لكن كنت ساكن
في مدينه المصافي الواقعه في قضاء بيجي
هاي المدينه اللي كل من زارها او سكن بها
يقول عليها انه هي جنه من جنان الله في
الارض كنا حابين نظل عايشين
هناك كنا حابين نظل عايشين هناك لكن حتى
يعني حتى والدتي كانت في كل مره نرجع بها
لهاي المدينه كانت تدعو دعاء تقول ربي لا
تحرمني من ها النعمه ردنا شي ولكن القدر
راد غير شي وتعلمت انه اذا القدر اراد
حيااته فلا بد ان يستجيب
البشر دخلوا داعش العراق ويوم 18/6
بالتحديد دخلوا
مدينتي دخلوها مثل ما دخلوا المغول
البغداد قدرنا نهرب منهم باعجوبه يعني حتى
اخذنا ويانا بالهروب مالتنا كان اخذنا
ويانا ملابس بسيطه
وخبز اطتي جيراننا ومي هربنا الى المجهول
بحثا عن الاستقرار المفقود من هنا بدات
رحله نازح مار خلالها باكثر من اربع
محافظات جربت بها العيش بفقر جربت بها
العيش بجوع مع العلم انا بالخير جربت بها
العيش بلا ماوى كانت هدفي انه انا احصل بس
غرفه انبات بها انا واهلي جربت ما جربت
لكن كل هذا ما احد من ارادتي
وعزيمتي ف ثرت على كل هاي الظروف
القهريه ثرت على كل ها الظروف القهريه
اللي كانت تريد ان تلغي كينونتي فقررت ان
اكون ثرت على كل ها الظروف اللا انسانيه
متمثله بداعش وقوانينها فقررت ان اكون
اكثر انسانيه من خلال الفن والموسيقى
فعلمت نفس
الرسم علمت نفس الرسم مع العلم اني ما كنت
اعرف ارسم من قبل وان انا ارسم بطريقه قد
تكون غير مطروقه من قبل علمت نفس العزف
على الكمان والان من خلال شراء ارخص اله
موسيقيه موجوده في كركوك على ب نفس
الالمانيه من خلال
جلوسي من خلال جلوسي على على حصير وعلى
غرفه بسيطه اكتشفت مهتي في الكتابه من
خلال كتابه مذكرات نازح اللي هي تمثل
قصتي قدرت انجح
بدراستي قدرت انجح بدراستي مع العلم انه
اني واجهت صعوبه بالغه في استحصال المقعد
الدراسي استضافه في جامعه بابل كل هذا
ليثبت العالم ونفسي اولا باني اذا اردت ان
اكون انسانا فلن يستطيع الوحوش منعي واذا
اردت ان اكون ناجحا فلن يجد الياس دربي
شكرا السلام عليكم اسمي نور من محافظه
المثنى جنت ادرس هندسه مرحله ثانيه
بكربلاء وبيوم كان عادي كلش لاحظت بقع زرق
بجسمي بعدها نزيف باللثه وفقدان توازن
مفاجئ قررت اروح للطبيب حتى اعرف شنو
اسبابها الاعراض وكانت النتيجه سرطان
بالدم بنسبه
85% قرر الدكتور يعالجني بدون ما يصارحني
بحقيقه
مرضي لكن اكتشفت المرض بعد ما تساقط
شعري لميته وقررت اخلي نفسي قبل الكل قدام
الامر الواقع حتى احارب
المرض تعرضت لهواي امور بسبب الكيمياوي
انحراف
بالعين تعرضت الفطريات سببت لي جروح
بلساني غده قررت خلاص حترك العلاج ويصير
اللي يصير وهنا ظهر الملاك دكتوري اللي هو
سبب وجودي اليوم
هنا فهمني انه غلط اللي اسويه ولازم استمر
ولازم احارب وبالفعل لان كان مؤمن انه انا
راح انتصر على الكانسر وصار وتحسنت تقريبا
وما بقى غير شي بسيط وعلى الانتصار
بالكامل
شكرا السلام
عليكم احمد خالد مواليدي
1993 قبل لا ابدي بقصتي احب
انطيها عنوان الطموح يصنع المعجزات ان
ولدت حالي حال اي انسان يركض يلعب يتونس
يضحك لمن صار عمري تسع سنين اكتشف ان انه
عندي مرض نادر جدا كل 15 مليون اكو
احصائيه تقول يصير بنفر واحد فقط اسمه
سباينل بايفيد
هالمرض سبب لي عواقب رجليه ان حرفا بمرور
الزمن هالمرض هذا عندي فتحه بالعمود
الفقري يصير بين فقره وفقره صاره فتحه بال
البرانش اللي توصل لرجليه هالمرض هذا ما
خلاني انه امنع دراستي او ابطل او اكون
يعني اتكاسل عن العمل كملت ثابرت نجحت
اعداديه
وطبيت جامعه كان حلمي وانا صغير اروح كليه
الصيدله لان هي الشغله اللي تناسب حالتي
للاسف المعدل ما اسعفني بالسادس رحت علوم
كيمياء اكو قانون عندنا اللي يطلع الاول
علوم كيمياء يروح يحول صيدله والحمد لله
طلعت الاول على قسم
[تصفيق]
الكيميا يجوز يجوز كل انسان من يحقق طموحه
يفرح بس للاسف انا ما فرحت بهاي الفتره
اسمع خبر كلش حزين انه اللي اللي الانسان
اللي كان عباره عن الطموح بالنسبه لي
والدي مصاب بمرض السرطان هالشي ما يمنعن
انه استمر ثابرت كملت قاتلت واني الان
طالب مرحله رابعه كليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصيدله اقول بالاخير وعندي موهبه شعريه
بسيطه الله اطان هل غم هذا الطموح يصنع من
الاهات طموح اقول انا راسم كل طموح من
الصغر واسعى من اجله وابد ما بدله يا زمن
لا تظن ابد تهزمني يوم حاي طاني وجاهز
الكل
معضله لكن القدر ما خلاني اكمل يعني لا
ماجستير ولا كملت حتى وظيفتي لهذا اللي
القدر اني اصبح عندي الام في منطقه معينه
من جسمي حاولت استاصل لكن
العمليه تفاقمت علي واصبح عندي يعني
مضاعفات ما بين روحه وجيه يعني واشكال
يعني تحاليل وكل الاشياء سويتها اكتشفت
انه اني مريضه بالاس ال اي الاس ال اي هو
داء الذب الاحمراري شنو داء الذب
الاحمراري اكتشف الدكتور قال ان هذا المرض
يؤدي ال يعني مرض
مناعي دي الى مهاجمه جميع انحاء الجسم
بهاي الحاله انا شو اسوي هاجم مفاصلي ظليت
فتره من فترات طويله انا اتعالج
المفاصل يعني بعدني ما خلصت هاجم عيوني
بعد بعد فتره هاجم الكلى مالتي الكلى هاي
كانت الطامه الكبرى بالنسبه لي استخدمت
الكيمياوي لكن بعد فتره من الفترات الحمد
لله والشكر قضيت على المرض كنت اقوى من
المرض وكان عندي امل بان اولادي ما شاء
الله عليهم يعني جميعهم متفوقين وجاني خبر
انه ما شاء الله اثنين من عندهم الكبار
اثنيناتهم طلعوا من الاوال على العراق
ودخلوا يعني كليات اللي هم كانوا حابها
زوجي كان سند الي دائما بحياتي لكن بعد
فتره من الفترات المرض ما استسلم ايضا ضرب
فتره من فترات الجهاز الهضمي الي اصابني
بالسرطان هذا السرطان الورم الشديد يعني
على اثره استاصل لي عمليتين جراحيتين لكن
ما يعني اني ما ازال واقفه على قدمي وما
ازال انا تلك الزو او تلك الام الاولادي
واني اشكر زام
عينكم شكرا جزيلا التوجه الصحيح للانسان
العادي نحو الهدف هو محاربه كل الظروف
الماساويه لكي يصل الى ذلك الهدف اما توجه
الانسان الكادح والمسحوق في هذه الحياه ان
يحارب تلك المعوقات لكي يبقى على قيد
الوجود اولا ومن ثم يسير نحو الهدف
حسين
حميد زيجه من نتاج الزواج التقليدي
العراقي قبع
وخذ لم
يكتب للعلاقه الزوجيه بين امي وابي
الاستمرار بعد سته اشهر من
ولادته بتاريخ
1995 عشت مع
والدتي مراره الحياه والفقر لدرجه انه هي
كانت تبيع الحصه التموينيه في سبيل توفر
مستلزم العيش اني من المرحله
الابتدائيه كنت اشتغل واكيد في سبيل اوفر
المصاريف
الدراسيه وجزء من مصاريف
البيت كل هذه الصعاب لا تجاري الالم الذي
استيقظت على اثره يوم 25/5 2014 بدون سبب
وبدون عارض مص بشلل تام عن
الحركه ضربتني موجه من مرض متلازمه قليان
بري
الحاد استمرت لمده 15 يوم شلل
صاعد احدثت ثلاث ازمات تنفسيه مميته كادت
تودي بحياتي ايضا وصلت ب درجه الشلل الى
اني اصبحت عاجز حتى عن فتح وغلق عيني اي
توقف كل شي عن الحركه بجسمي
الاطباء ورؤى الناس كانت تقتصر على ان هم
يريدون بس يشوفوني على كرسي متحرك لا مريد
حسين يشوفه على سرير خلي علي خلي عادي بس
كرسي
متحر
بس المشكله اني كنت
اريد واني كنت اطمح
اوقف
و كنت كل ما اسمع راي سلبي لاي انسان واي
طبيب ارجع للبيت امارس العلاج الطبيعي
بعنف و
بضراوه لدرجه انه كنت اذا امارس العلاج
طبيعي ساعتين كنت كل ما ارجع من الطبيب
امارسه اربع ساعات بس في سبيل اعده بس في
سبيل
اكسره وبعد ممارسه هذ العلاج احب اوجه
رساله للدكتور وبقيه الناس
[موسيقى]
وهي
[تصفيق]
شكرا اتوجه الى اخي
العراقي هذا الوطن جسد كجسد الانسان
الماثل امامك جسد
معاق لا التذمر ولا الياس ولا التخاذل ولا
التراجع هي وسائل لحل مشاكل هذا الواقع
وحدها الاراده والقوه والوقوف بوجه الظلم
هي من ستعالج هذا الواقع شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جزيلا y